>> WE'RE GOING TO BE VERY
STRONG ON BACKGROUND CHECKS.
WE WILL BE DOING VERY STRONG
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
VERY STRONG EMPHASIS ON THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF SOMEBODY.
AND WE ARE GOING TO DO
PLENTY OF OTHER THINGS.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON TOO LONG.
TOO MANY INSTANCES AND WE'RE
GOING TO GET IT DONE.
>> THIS SOLUTION IS NOT
GOING TO BE A SINGULAR
THING.
IT'S GOING TO BE
MULTI-FACETED AND IT'S GOING
TO BE CREATED BY A
COLLECTION OF DIFFERENT
PEOPLE WORKING TOGETHER.
>> PEOPLE ARE DYING.
AND WE HAVE TO STOP THIS.
WE HAVE TO STOP IT.
IF HE IS NOT OLD ENOUGH TO
BUY A DRINK, TO GO AND BUY A
BEER, HE SHOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO BUY A GUN AT 18 YEARS
OLD.
>> FIX IT.
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN ONE
SCHOOL SHOOTING AND WE
SHOULD HAVE FIXED IT.
AND I'M PISSED.
BECAUSE MY DAUGHTER I'M NOT
GOING TO SEE AGAIN.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT
HOLDING A VERY EMOTIONAL
LISTENING SESSION AT THE
WHITE HOUSE EARLIER TODAY ON
THE ISSUE OF SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR TOMI
LAHREN IS WITH US TURNING
POINT U.S.A. FOUNDER CHARLIE
KIRK AND RNC SPOKESPERSON
CAILEE MAC ENY ARE WITH US.
TO ME THE SOLUTION IS
SIMPLE.
IS THAT EVERY SCHOOL SHOULD
HAVE A FULL THREAT
ASSESSMENT, SECURITY
ASSESSMENT, RETIRED, ARMED,
MILITARY RETIRED ARMED
POLICE NEED TO BE IN THE
SCHOOLS TO BE A FRONT LINE
OF DEFENSE AND MANY SAID
THAT TONIGHT.
>> WELL, I THINK THAT'S THE
LOGICAL SOLUTION BUT ANY
TIME OF TRAGEDY IT'S FILLED
WITH EMOTION, AS IT SHOULD
BE.
I THINK WE SHOULD ALL BE
VERY HONEST YOURSELVES.
>> IT'S A TRAGIC TIME AND
LET THE VICTIMS AND FAMILIES
GRIEVE.
WE NEED TO LET THEM SPEAK.
I THINK EVERYONE HERE
BECAUSE WE ARE FIRST
AMENDMENT ADVOCATES BELIEVE
EVERYBODY ON EITHER SIDE OF
THE ISSUE HAS THE RIGHT TO
SPEAK ON THE ISSUE AND WE
CAN COME TO SOME KIND OF
CONSENSUS.
WE ALSO NEED TO TACKLE THE
CULTURAL PROBLEMS AT PLAY.
IT'S NOT JUST A GUN PROBLEM.
WE SHOULD HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Sean: IT HAS TO BE BOTH.
IF WE DECIDED CHARLIE WE
WANTED EVERY SINGLE SCHOOL
IN AMERICA SAFE, WE COULD DO
THAT WE ARE CAPABLE OF DOING
BIG THINGS.
>> YOU BRING A GREAT POINT
ABOUT THE THREAT SEA.
ASSESSMENT.
IT'S AMAZING HOW MANY
SCHOOLS HAVE NOT BEEN
PROPERLY ANALYZED AND DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO IN THE
THREAT OF A SHOOTING.
IN MOMENTS LIKE THESE IT
WILL DEFINE THE NATION'S
CHARACTER.
WE SHOULD BE DEEPLY TROUBLED
BY WHAT HAPPENED.
WE ALSO HAVE TO STAY
PRINCIPLED TO WHAT WE AS
FREEDOM LOVING AMERICANS
REALLY BELIEVE.
THIS IS REALLY WHERE IT IS
GOING TO TAKE TO US DOUBLE
DOWN AND SAY YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE DO THINK WE SHOULD HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH CHECKS BUT
SHOULDN'T SACRIFICE SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
>> SECURING THESE SCHOOLS,
WE HEARD THE FATHER WHO LOST
HIS DAUGHTER IN SOUND BITE.
WHEN 9/11 HAPPENED GUESS
WHAT WE SECURED OUR
AIRPORTS.
IT SHOULD HAVE TAKEN ONE OF
THESE NOT SEVERAL.
I WANT TO POINT OUT DARRYL
SCOTT, I SENT ON THE BOARD
OF RACHEL'S CHALLENGE WHO
LOST HIS DAUGHTER.
RACHEL WHO LOST HIS DAUGHTER
IN THE COLUMBINE MASSACRE HE
HAS BEEN WORKING ON
SOLUTIONS FOR 20 YEARS.
WHEN TOMI TALKS ABOUT
CULTURAL CHANGE SHE IS SPOT
ON THERE.
WE HAVE LOST RESPECT FOR ONE
ANOTHER.
YOUR CLASSMATE IS YOUR
FRIEND THAT NEEDS TO BE
IM34RE789ED MORE THAN
ANYTHING.
>> Sean: WE SIT THERE AROUND
THE TABLE IS THIS.
IT'S CRAZY, RIGHT?
>> IT'S AWARENESS ISSUE.
BEYOND THAT WHETHER WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT TERRORISM AND
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
SAFETY IN GENERAL.
IT'S AN AWARENESS ISSUE.
LIKE YOU MENTIONED PEOPLE
ARE BURIED IN THEIR PHONES
AND NOT PAYING TENSION.
TAKING PICTURES ON
INSTAGRAM.
NOT AWARE WHAT'S AROUND
THEM.
THAT LEADS TO LESS SAFETY IN
OUR MALLS AND ON THE
AIRPORTS AND STREETS.
>> YOU COULD TAKE THE GUNS
AWAY
ABAY
ABUT THAT'S NOT A
POSSIBILITY.
BE VERY CAREFUL IN MOMENTS
LIKE THESE TO GIVE AWAY YOUR
FREEDOMS BECAUSE WHEN YOU DO
YOU ARE NEVER GOING TO GET
THEM BACK.
>> Sean: LAST WORD,
KAYLEIGH.
>> HAVE YOU TAKEN GOT OUT OF
OUR SCHOOLS AND TAKEN GOD
OUT OF OUR SOCIETY YOU WILL
SEE MORE AND MORE OF THIS
HAPPY ON A DAILY BASIS.
>> Sean: EXACTLY RIGHT.
I REALLY DO.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE THREE
YOUNG PEOPLE AND THERE ARE
SO MANY THAT ARE COMING TO
CPAC WHICH OPENED TODAY AND
THEY WILL BE HERE FOR THE
VICE PRESIDENT TOMORROW AND
THE PRESIDENT ON FRIDAY.
YOU GUYS ARE DEFINITELY